[Music]
what if I told you a story about heart
we all have a heart and that heart needs
to be set free
imagine a bakery
a man
[Music]
he's an all-american hero Heisman Trophy
winner he fought in World War two and in
Korea he was also in Vietnam not the war
just vacationing yet one year
hardest-working man you've ever met
harder working than any of his employees
try as they may they just couldn't
outwork him but some people don't have a
heart and sometimes those people are
your son he was as foul-mouthed as they
come where are you from lady that's
where all the are from am i
respecting my smells like a I wouldn't
be either
ha ha ha ha ha yeah you know speaking
English ha ha ha ha I hope you all get
AIDS are you too stupid why you guys
don't understand jokes go Trump but like
most pure geniuses it was also a
degenerate party animal
[Music]
then one day he's wasted flips his car
he survives but his brain is damaged the
father however besides
still has him come work at the bakery
[Music]
then one day the father gets call from a
doctor who explains to him that they can
return his son to his previous mental
state through the miracle of surgery
however in order to perform this surgery
the father needs to sign off on it
because the son can't make decisions
like that in his current mental state so
the father now has to decide
keep the son like he is happy or return
him to us
haha what off him rods I'm back you
missed me
yeah I was a vegetable for a while
enough I mean well I was a cucumber no
Teddy I was just a teeny Oh
oh my god doing you as a doctor because
once again
we could hear them yeah that's a really
great movie idea
so the do you want a cappuccino or
macchiato the tap water